Liz truss was the Prime Minister of
broken promises she caused a near
meltdown of the markets nearly all her
unfunded plans for tax cuts were
reversed now she's out the shortest
serving prime minister in UK history I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
[Music]
her undoing started last Friday she
sacked her Finance Minister kwazi
quateng but blaming him for getting it
wrong had no effect on the markets the
pound wasn't recovering and the cost of
government borrowing was still going up
a nervous truss walked out on questions
in came political heavyweight Jeremy
Hunt as new Chancellor trashing
virtually all of the trust plans saving
billions of dollars and calming the
markets
economic credibility God the next day
she was confronted by opposition labor
leader Kia stahmer for the first time
she seemed to be defiant I am a fighter
and not a quetter
thank you for 24 hours later she were
told to quit now the conservative party
is engulfed in leadership elections
again and those in charge say they'll
have to be quick I think we're deeply
conscious of the imperative and the
national interest of resolving this
clearly and quickly
contenders include former Chancellor
Rishi sulak but there's still anger in
the party over his part in bringing down
Boris Johnson and Johnson does look like
trying to make a comeback his allies say
it would be in the National interest
Penny mordant leader of the House of
Commons may be a good Unity candidate
but may not have enough experience to
convince the party
and as the country is facing a change of
prime minister for the third time in
three months the opposition is calling
for a general election we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
the conservative party is split it's
damaged and it's still shaken by what's
happened the last thing it needs right
now is a general election opinion polls
show it would be decimated Andrew
Simmons Al Jazeera Downing Street